اقل من اسبوع على الانتخابات التشريعيه في
تونس السجال السياسي يتصاعد وتزداد
وتسيرته مع دعوه اتحاد الشغل للرئيس قيس
سعيد الى التراجع عما سماها سياسه التعنف
الاتحاد ايضا يحمل الرئيس مسؤوليه
الانسداد وما ينتج عنه اما الرئيس قيس
سعيد وقبل مغادرته الى واشنطن يجدده هجومه
على المعارضه ويقول ان قوه المعارضه همها
السلطه ويلمح الى علاقاتها باطراف خارجي
اذا نبه الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل من
تواصل تازم الوضعيه الاقتصادي والاجتماعي
في البلاد وحذر الحكومه من الاستمرار في
ما وصفها بسياسه الارتجال وانعدام الكفاءه
في مجابهه الازمه في تونس وقال الامين
العام الاتحاد التونسي للشغل نور الدين
الطبوبي ان البلاد تعيش ما وصفه لمنعرج
خطير ودعى الرئيس للقيام بخطوات الى
الوراء من اجل الوحده الوطنيه وجدد رفض
الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل رفعت دعمي
على المواد الاساسيه وتحويل ملكيه
المؤسسات العامه للخواص كما نفى مشاركه
المنظمه في صياغه البرنامج الاقتصادي
للحكومه ومعرفه بما ابرمته مع صندوق النقد
الدولي
قالت الرئاسه التونسيه ان الرئيس قيس سعيد
غادر البلاد الى واشنطن للمشاركه في
الدوره الثانيه لقمه قاده الولايات
المتحده وافريقيا وقبيل مغادرته وجه سعيد
انتقادات للمعارضه متهمه اياها بالسعي
وراء السلطه وعدم المباله بمطالب التونسيه
جاءت تلك التصريحات خلال زياره سعيد
لاحياء في ولايه اريانا للاطلاع على
الاوضاع الصعبه التي يعيشها السكان واشار
سعيد الى انه لاهم للمعارضه والسلطه ولا
تعنيها المطالب الحقيقيه للشعب التونسي
سعيد اتهم المعارضه بافراغ خزائن الدوله
في السابق الى جانب تحالفاتها المعروفه في
الخارج